Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking it.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to you by Wealthfront and this is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive in a good way,
set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under management.
In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why?
Why is it so popular?
Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them,
and this is because they use smarter software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams,
et cetera.
And I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they'd put you in and if you just want to take their
advice,
run with it,
do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it and here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular basis but normally aren't great investing
is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may or may not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of time.
Wealthfront,
as I mentioned,
since it's using software instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low costs that were previously completely
impossible right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim,
that is less than $5 a month to invest a $30,000 account for instance.
Now,
normally when I have a sponsor on this show,
it's because I use them and recommend them.
In this case,
it's a little different.
I don't use wealth front yet because I'm not allowed to.
Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of sec regulations,
companies that invest your money are not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user end have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money,
at least for me,
uh,
in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if you decide to open an account.
But just start with seeing the portfolio that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes,
fill out their questionnaire@wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim It's fast.
It's,
there's no downside that I can think of.
So check it out guys.
This is one of the hottest,
most innovative companies coming out of Silicon Valley and they're killing it.
They've become massively popular.
Just take a look,
see what portfolio they would create for you,
and you can use that information however you want.
wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim
this episode is brought to you by me undies.
If I'm not going commando,
I'm in me.
Andy's,
I have been testing these underwear for three to four months now pretty much
every day and in fact throughout bunch of my other underwear this morning and on
the road in the house,
they are extremely comfortable.
They look good,
feel good.
They are made of micro model two times softer than cotton and scientifically
tested using the [inaudible] method.
Sounds very fancy.
Of course,
and I get a lot of compliments from ladies for these.
You don't get diaper butt,
you don't get the tired elastic band.
They look great.
And they have underwear for both men and women.
Check out [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim and you can see everything that
I've been wearing.
They're ridiculous.
The sublime,
everything in between,
including my favorite,
which is called out.
And I would be remiss if I didn't mention their lounge pants.
This is a new thing.
And I had been wearing their lounge pants when I record podcast.
I've been wearing them out and about when I'm walking the dog meeting people for
coffee.
And they are extremely comfortable though.
They're made from the same material as the underwear.
But some of them,
like the blue ones,
I have have pockets so you can walk about without seeming like you're off of
your meds and completely crazy.
So that is awesome.
And if you're not happy with the first pair you try on,
I assume that refers to the underwear,
they'll refund you completely and you can keep the pair you tried on for free.
But if you're that kind of person,
you should be ashamed because that's disgusting.
Uh,
[inaudible] dot com four slash Tim,
check it out.
Yeah.
Derek,
welcome to the show.
Thank you.
I am so excited to have you on.
This has been in the works for for many months
now.
Of course the timing is such,
and I'm going to read a bio and a short intro for you for folks in a second.
But,
uh,
we're going to come back to the subject of fasting because I'm eight days into a
10 day fast.
And I was astonished to hear when we were chatting a day or two ago that you
have done something very similar,
if not the same.
So before we get to that though,
for everybody listening,
uh,
Derek Sivers,
one of my favorite humans,
so excited to have him on the phone.
And a,
here is a sketch of his background.
Originally a professional musician and circus clown.
Derek Sivers,
you should say hi to him at Sivers on the Twitter.
That is Siv.
E R s created CD baby in 1998 became the largest seller of independent music
online with 100 million in sales for 150,000 musicians in 2008,
Derek sold CD baby for 22 million,
giving the proceeds to a charitable trust for music education.
He is and has been a frequent on the Ted Conference circuit with more than 5
million views of his talks.
And since 2011 he has published 24 books including anything you want,
which shot to number one on all of its Amazon categories.
It is also one of the few business books which I think categorically are
generally terrible that I've not only read multiple times but listened to uh,
multiple times of the last of which was in Sweden about a month and a half ago
before deciding to take my startup vacation effectively my retirement from
startup investing.
So Derek,
thank you for putting out such good work first before we even jump into it.
Thanks.
Good to find that.
Well,
you know,
officially talk to you off the record,
which is kind of funny sometimes because,
uh,
every now and then people ask me about like,
Hey,
do you know what Tim's investing in,
you know about this?
And I think,
you know,
every time you and I talk we just,
we talk about women.
So here we are having an official conversation finally.
No,
we are,
and I should also underscore for people,
number one,
I'm eight days into fasting.
So if I sound like an idiot,
I'm going to blame it on that.
But second is that I consider you a reality check for me.
And we first met,
I want to say it was that a music and tech or tech and music event in 2007
perhaps 2000.
Yep.
And uh,
I was familiar with some of your work.
You had read the four hour workweek.
And the,
the prompt for me to call you oftentimes is,
is number one.
If I just need a sanity check where for instance,
if people around me seem to be asking the question,
how should you best grow your company?
And then there's an ABC multiple choice list.
I don't necessarily go to you to get a d in an e.
I go to you because you,
you will say,
well,
why do you want to grow your company in the first place?
Ask the wrong question.
And secondly,
because you're very good at simplifying and breaking things down.
And I recall,
and I might be getting low the location wrong,
but I seem to place this in time square,
sitting on the bleachers talking about,
I think it was sequel and databases and I was saying that I was extremely
uncomfortable.
It felt out of my depth when talking to engineers and you're like,
oh,
it's not that hard.
And you sat down and on a single page,
a piece of paper sketched out databases and sequel and how it worked.
And I just admire the,
not only capability,
which is not that common,
but the willingness to simplify something where I think we live in a world where
many people complicate to profit,
right?
If what you do is,
if what you do is simple,
then you feel like you're dispensable,
if that makes sense.
And,
uh,
but I want to stop talking and ask you because I'm not sure I actually ever
heard the full story
of originally a professional musician and circus clown and water.
What is the circus cloud story?
Okay.
There's actually a good lesson inside the story is that I was 18 years old and
all I wanted in my whole life was to be a professional musician.
I mean,
ideally a rockstar.
Yeah.
But if I was just making my living doing music,
that was the goal.
So I'm 18 years old,
I'm living in Boston,
I'm going to Berklee College of music and I'm in this band,
uh,
where the bass player one day in rehearsal says,
hey man,
um,
my agent just offered me a Gig that's like $75 to play at a pig show in Vermont.
He rolls his eyes and he's like,
I'm not going to do it.
Do you want the Gig?
I'm like,
fuck yeah,
a paying gig.
Oh my God.
Yes.
So,
uh,
I took the Gig to go up to Burlington,
Vermont and I think it was like a,
you know,
$58 round trip bus ticket.
And I get to this pig show in Vermont.
I strapped my acoustic guitar and then I walk around a pig show playing music
and uh,
did that for like three hours,
got on the bus home and the next day the booking agent called me up and said,
uh,
hey.
So well,
yeah,
you did a really good job at the big show.
We got good reports there.
I'm wondering if you can come play at an art opening in western Massachusetts a,
I'll pay you 75 bucks again.
I said,
yeah,
sure.
So same thing.
I took the,
you know,
like a $60 bus out to western Massachusetts,
got 75 bucks for playing at an art opening and the agent was there and he was
impressed.
And so he said,
Hey,
look,
I've got this circus,
uh,
and the previous musician just quit.
So we really need somebody new and I really like what you're doing.
So there's a about three gigs a week,
I can pay you 75 bucks a Gig.
Uh,
they're usually Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
Uh,
do you want the Gig?
I said,
hell yeah,
I'm a professional musician.
Now,
this is amazing.
So,
so I said yes to everything which is going to come up later.
You know what the hell yeah or no thing that I think it's really smart to switch
strategies.
But when you're earlier in your career,
I think the best strategies,
you just say yes to everything,
every piddly little Gig,
you just never know what are the lottery tickets.
So this one ended up being a real lottery ticket for me because as soon as I
joined the circus again,
I'm 18.
I had no stage experience.
And uh,
with after a few gigs they said,
hey,
so the previous musician used to go out and open the show with this big theme
song and get everybody up and dancing.
Could you do that?
And I said,
yeah,
sure.
And another Gig or two later they said,
hey,
the previous musician used to close the show also with that theme song.
Could you do that?
I said,
yeah,
sure.
And then it was the previous musician used to go out in between every act and
like,
you know,
get the audience to applaud and thank them and introduce the next act.
Do you think you could do that?
I said,
yeah,
sure.
And I was really bad at it at first,
but I got good.
Eventually I became like the ringleader mc of this whole circus and I was 18
years old.
So if you were to go to the circus,
it would have looked like my show.
And I did that for 10 years.
From the age of 18 to 28 I did over a thousand shows and eventually by the way,
cut paid more than 75 bucks.
Eventually I was getting like 300 bucks a show and it became my full time living
and I even bought a house with the money I made playing with the circuits.
And then that led to all kinds of other things.
So just so many huge opportunities in 10 years of stage experience came from
that one piddly little pig show.
And I said yesterday,
the civil thing.
Um,
so yeah,
the only reason I stopped doing the circus is when CD baby started taking over
my life and I had to start turning down circus gigs.
But yeah,
that was my life for 10 years.
What did you learn that made you better?
What were the,
the lessons learned that made the biggest difference in your performance as this
mc?
Good question.
It was,
or the biggest mistakes that you made early on that you corrected?
Either one's fine.
All right.
Um,
it's kind of the same answers that at first I was too self conscious because I
thought it was about me.
Like I was going up on stage thinking that the audience was somehow judging me.
Derek silver is like as if I mattered,
you know,
so I would get self conscious what they thought of me.
And eventually,
and I think it took maybe like 10 or 20 gigs with the,
the,
the circus was run by a husband and wife team.
And uh,
Tarleton was the name of the wife that,
um,
she was the one really kind of out on the gigs and leading the circus.
The husband was more of the booking agent and she's the one that like single
handedly gave me my confidence that I have today.
Like sometimes when people ask me,
why am I so confident?
It's like that's because of Tarleton.
That's a longer story we get into.
But anyway,
Tarleton is the one that she just kept pushing me from backstage.
It's like,
come on,
you're,
you're up there acting like David Letterman.
Like don't,
don't do this whole kind of a high,
yeah,
I'm so cool.
Alright everybody here is the next act.
Like I think I was trying to be cool because I thought that people were judging
me.
Right?
And she said,
these people came here for a show.
Go give them what they came here for.
And so one time I decided to go out there and just be over the top.
Ridiculous.
I went on stage and I said,
ladies and gentlemen,
what you're about to see is one of the most amazing,
you get to get a,
we have an elephant that is going to be coming from backstage.
And I did this whole like thing and the fast talking voice and a real like
pizzazz to it and the audience loved it.
And I came backstage and she said,
there you go.
That's what people come to the circus for.
So now that I've been on stage,
you know,
thousands of times I that's this really sunk in that you get on stage to give
the audience what they came there for.
Or even things like this,
this interview we're doing,
this isn't necessarily for you or me,
we could just hang up the phone and talk.
We don't need to,
but we're doing this for the listeners.
So we're going to give them something that's useful to them.
This isn't about me.
It isn't about you.
This is about them.
So that was the biggest lesson learned.
Luckily I learned that early on when I was 18,
19 and yeah,
so I know he could come back to it,
but I don't want to forget since I have low,
low glucose brain,
which I think I just made Japanese accidentally.
But uh,
so how did she give you your confidence or if you prefer to answer it a
different way?
Because I get this question a lot from fans on Twitter for instance,
you know,
how did you get so confident?
And there are things I can point to from athletic training with specific
wrestling coaches and so on.
But if,
if what did that woman do that that helped make you more to help make you more
confident?
Or if you were trying to coach somebody who's going to get up and give their
first ted talk,
what would you say to them?
And I don't know if the answers are similar,
completely different answers.
So we'll just do the confidence one.
I can,
I can give Ted talk advice later if you want.
Is that in my case?
Um,
you gotta understand Tarleton was hot.
I was 18 and she was 33 and even the first time I ever saw her,
it,
I told you that she was the,
the booking agent's wife.
So when I took that bus out to western Massachusetts the first time I'm sitting
in the Worcester mass bus station,
it's nasty.
It's the,
you know,
the dregs of the earth with fluids dripping.
And uh,
it,
it's gross.
And I'm sitting there waiting for somebody to pick me up and then like the door
opens to the bus station.
And it's like that scene in the movie with the backlit woman and you know,
the fan blowing her hair and the dream weaver,
you know,
is that moment,
this gorgeous woman walks in the bus station.
I'm like,
oh,
is that,
and she walks towards me and she says,
Derrick.
And I was like,
so that was Tarleton.
So it's important to know that Charleston is hot.
She still is.
And so,
you know,
I was 18 and,
and uh,
I was dating girls in Boston and uh,
of course just everybody broke my heart and this one girl from Texas just dumped
me and I would sad.
And at that point Tarleton and I had been traveling together on the circus for a
year or so.
So she knew me very well.
And,
uh,
when I told her about the,
you know,
the girl from Texas that dumped me,
she just said,
Derrick,
like you don't understand.
Like I've met a lot of guys in my life,
a lot of guys,
she said,
you are one of like the smartest was brilliant.
Like consider it like you've got a future,
you've got your shit together.
You're like,
if some woman doesn't see that,
that's her problem.
Okay.
So the first like a hundred times she said this,
I just thought she was just being nice,
you know?
I was like,
no,
you,
but I'm still sad.
And I think it took about a year where she just kept telling me this and kept
telling me this.
And after about a year,
it kind of sunk in.
Like I just noticed that I had kind of internalized this like,
yeah,
sorry,
and you can't see me right now,
but I'm just like,
you know,
changed my posture.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm pretty fucking awesome.
I'm cool.
I'm like,
I really internalized that.
So I just carried that with me ever since.
You know,
sometimes there's this beautiful Kurt Vonnegut quote that's a,
just a throwaway line in the middle of one of his books that says,
you are whatever you pretend to be such a good line.
And I took that to heart that I just thought,
you know,
I'd also been reading Tony Robbins and stuff by then.
Actually she,
Oh God,
Tarleton.
Is that the same woman that she's the one that told me to read Tony Robbins
awaken the giant within when I was 19 and that changed my life.
So yeah,
she's one of like the big three influences on my life.
That's probably exact same age that I read the exact same book.
Just as a side note,
that is the good time to read it,
those formative years.
So,
um,
yeah,
I,
I think the you are whatever you pretend to be.
I think I just realized somewhere in there that you can just choose to be
confident.
Um,
she helped kind of start it for me,
but then I,
I kept it up myself even when everything is going terribly and I have no reason
to be confident.
I just decide to be,
it seems like most of my friends who are,
what most people would consider successful in various respects can trace their
confidence back to either or both end a specific woman and a space and a
specific coach or mentor of some type.
It's all,
it almost always comes down to one or both of those.
Oh Damn.
You know,
I've never told you about Kimo Williams.
It's a great name and I want to learn more.
No,
I don't know anything about this is so up your alley.
I can't believe I've never told you this.
Okay,
thanks.
[inaudible] you prompted me with that because you're right,
it was a gorgeous woman,
Tarleton and it was a music teacher Kimo Williams that he but see,
he changed my life a year or two before I met her.
Okay.
So imagine this,
I'm 17 years old now.
I'm living in suburban Chicago and I decided to go to Berklee College of music
because I want to be a famous musician.
And just like two or three months before I'm supposed to go,
uh,
I see an ad in the local Chicago Tribune for music type setting.
And I'm wondering like,
how much sheet music I'm going to have to be writing?
So I call up this classified ad in the paper and I say,
can I ask you some questions about music typesetting?
And he said,
sure.
Well why do you want to know?
And I said,
because I'm about to go off to Berkeley College of music in a couple months.
And he said,
oh,
really?
He said,
I used to teach at Berkeley College of music.
I said,
you did,
um,
do you think you can give me some tips?
And he said,
yeah,
um,
here's my address.
Come to my studio at 9:00 AM Thursday morning.
See you then.
Uh,
so,
and he lived like way downtown Chicago in an area I've never been to.
And I'm going to do a little foreshadowing of the story perfect right now
because,
uh,
when I got married years later,
to the woman I met when I was sitting in Times Square with you,
uh,
he was one of only three people I invited to the wedding.
Uh,
it was Tarleton from the circus.
Kimo Williams,
my music teacher and my first girlfriend can be all,
those are my only three guests to my wedding.
And Kimo Williams told the story to my family.
He said,
you know,
I tell people all the time,
I get all these kids that want,
you know,
want to be famous.
And I said,
Yep,
show up at my studio at 9:00 AM.
And he said,
nobody ever does.
Nobody has their shit together to show up when I tell them too.
And he said,
so I'd honestly forgotten that there was this kid that called from a classified
ad
that was his way of saying no,
no,
was not.
No,
it was just his hurdle.
He was like,
yeah,
all right kid.
Sure.
Here's a seven foot hurdle to you do.
Exactly.
So,
uh,
he said,
so,
you know,
my doorbell rings some Thursday morning at 8:59 AM and I opened the door and
there was some long haired teenagers sitting there and you know,
so now flipping back to a first person point of view is,
uh,
yeah.
Kimo Williams is this a large black man from Hawaii that was a musician that
attended Berklee school of music and then stayed there to teach for awhile.
And so what he taught me in for lessons got me to graduate Berklee College of
music in half the time it would take.
And here was his thing.
He said,
the reason I wanted you to like study with me for a bit,
he said,
I know you only have like eight weeks before you go to school.
He said,
I think you can graduate Berklee School of music in two years instead of four.
Um,
he said,
the standard pace is for chumps.
I should get a tee shirt made that Tim Ferriss' stuff right then was like,
I can't believe we hadn't talked about this before,
that he's the one at the age of like 17,
18 got me into this mentality.
He said were the standard pace is for chumps.
That's the school has to organize it's curricula around the lowest common
denominator so that almost nobody is left out.
So they have to slow down so that everybody can catch up.
But he said,
you're smarter than that,
or anybody can be smarter than that if they want to be so you can go as fast as
you want.
And here's how,
uh,
and so he sat me down at the piano.
He said,
okay,
what do you know about music theory?
I said,
well,
I don't know.
Let's find out.
And He,
you know,
he just asked me a few of these music questions like,
okay,
what,
how does it make your skill boat to dot,
right?
Okay,
show me the try.
Don't do you know what to try?
Tone is okay.
Planning.
He tried tone in the c major scale.
I'm like,
AH,
okay.
Bnf he said,
okay,
now,
uh,
how can you take that and what other chord can you make from BNF?
He said,
okay,
that's called the substitute court.
Now what does the resolution we were like,
and he would just like,
don't,
don't it,
this kind of plays.
He was doing all this music theory stuff with me.
It was so intense and I was like,
I had all this adrenaline,
like a video game.
I was like,
this is amazing.
Okay,
keep going.
Is it okay that yes it does.
And that was like a two hour lesson that went at that kind of pace.
And then he'd dumped a bunch of homework on me.
He said,
okay,
now go home tonight and take this big book of jazz standards.
Find me all the two five substitutions or a two five closures.
Now substitute chords for that and then come back next Thursday and we'll do
this again.
So we did that for like four Thursdays in a row.
And sure enough,
what he taught me in four,
two hour sessions was basically like two years of Berkeley College of music.
He compressed it into four lessons.
Wow.
So that when I showed up to my first day of Berkeley,
I tested out of the first few years
just thanks to him.
And then he even taught me his strategy.
It just offhand mentioned,
he said,
you know,
I think they might still have a rule in place where,
uh,
those other required courses,
you know,
that you have to take to graduate.
He said,
I think you could pretty much just buy the books for those and then contact the
department head and just take the final exam to get credit.
So I did that too.
So I,
uh,
when I got there,
all those required classes,
like,
you know,
a Bach counterpoint classes,
I wasn't so interested in it.
So I bought the book,
did all the homework approach to the department head,
said,
can I take the final exam for this?
And he said,
looked at me weird and said,
okay,
took the final exam and got credit without ever having to attend the class.
And uh,
yeah,
that's how I graduated Berklee College of music in two years.
That's incredible.
What a gift.
I mean,
did he,
did he ever,
aside from just showing up,
which is of course half the battle,
if not more than half the battle,
did he ever explain to you why he adopted you in that way?
Were you the first person for student he'd done that for or is this something
he'd done before?
I think he,
yeah,
he's definitely done it before and since.
So as far as I know,
last time we spoke,
spoke,
he's still teaching at Columbia College in downtown Chicago in the music
department.
So I think he's done this for many people since he's just an amazing guy that is
just a great teacher,
a very strict teacher.
He calls everybody to a really high standard,
you know,
that kind of,
that whole,
like if he said show up at my studio at 9:00 AM,
if I would have rang the doorbell at nine 10,
he would have said,
hmm,
guess you're not serious.
And he probably would have turned me away,
you know?
Uh,
so he,
he does that with his students and um,
yeah,
so he's done that for many people before and since I think.
What would he say to you if you recall when you did something incorrectly?
How did he provide feedback?
Hm,
well I think,
think for specific things.
He just Kinda give me that raised eyebrow look like,
Oh really?
You think that that is that I said,
but you know what,
here's,
it's kind of the,
to your question is he would question things.
Um,
kind of like you were talking about,
you know,
calling me when wondering if people are asking the right question.
So when I first Kahn,
that very first phone call,
right?
I said,
I'm going to go to Berklee College of Music in eight weeks.
And he said,
really?
Why do you want to go to Berkeley?
And I said,
well,
because I want to be famous,
successful singer,
songwriter,
performer.
He said,
hmm.
well,
four years and $100,000 in tuition.
It's a lot of money to learn to read or write a verse and a chorus
like that kind of thing.
Like,
Oh really?
Is that,
is that really the reason you're doing this?
Like just constantly questioning.
That's,
that's so incredibly,
especially at that age.
I mean,
what an incredible molting that he provided.
And ever since then,
I mean,
you know,
you and I have often the same approach to life.
Like looking for the looking for the shortcuts are just kind of more like
looking at the way that most people do things and saying like,
you know,
that's,
you don't have to do it that way.
That's very inefficient.
You could just do this.
So he just gave me that approach to life.
It's great.
And unrelated note,
uh,
could you talk about,
and we've,
we've talked about this a bit,
but I never tire of it relaxing for the same result because I think this is such
a huge,
uh,
observation that it's,
it's incredibly important for type a personalities are,
or at least for me,
because I have a tendency to almost want to burn the candle at both ends to
prove to myself that I'm putting forth the maximum effort.
I'm not,
I'm leaving as little as possible to chance with certain,
with certain things,
you know,
and uh,
but tell,
tell everybody about the,
the bike about the bicycle experience.
Yeah.
This was kind of profound.
Um,
now granted I didn't learn this until later,
but yeah,
I had been very,
very,
very type a my whole life even before I met Kimo Williams,
you know what I mean?
Age of 14.
It's just my friends called me the robot because they would never see me sleep
or eat or relax or hang out.
I just was like so focused on being the best musician I could be that I would
just practice every waking minute.
Um,
if I'd be grudgingly go to a party,
you know,
I bring my guitar with me and I'd be sitting in the corner practicing my scales
and Arpeggios while everybody was hanging out,
getting high,
you know.
So,
um,
so yeah,
I've always been very type A and so a friend of mine got me into cycling when I
was living in La and I lived right on the beach in Santa Monica where there's
this great bike path in the sand that goes for,
I think it's 25 miles in the sand.
Uh,
25th,
no,
hold on,
something like that.
The exact number doesn't matter.
But what I would do is I would go on to the bike path and I would get like head
down and push it as hard as I could.
I would go all the way to one end of the bike path and back and then back home.
And I'd set my little timer when doing this huffing and puffing red face,
red face huffing it.
But like,
just pushing it as hard as I can,
every single,
you know,
thrust of the leg.
And,
uh,
of course,
you know,
that may be quite fun if somebody was in my way on the bike path.
I'm sure you're like,
God,
that guy's got places to go.
So,
but I noticed it was always 43 minutes.
I mean,
you know,
if you know Santa Monica,
California,
you know,
the weather is about exactly the same all year round.
So,
um,
unless it was a surprisingly windy day,
it was always 43 minutes is what it took me to go as fast as I could for that on
that bike path.
But I noticed that over time I was starting to feel less psyched about going out
on the bike path because just mentally when I would think of it,
it would feel like pain and hard work.
It sounds like pain and hard work.
Yeah.
I mean it was,
but you know,
it,
I guess at first that was okay.
And after a while it just felt like,
ah,
I don't know,
riding the bike.
Why don't I just hang out?
Um,
so then I said,
you know,
that's no,
that's not cool for me to start to associate negative stuff with going on the
bike ride.
Why don't I just chill for one,
it's like I'm just going to go on the same bike ride but just,
you know,
I'm not going to be a complete,
it was snail and,
but I'll go with like half of my normal pace.
So yeah,
I got on my bike and it was just pleasant.
I just went on the same bike ride,
but I was more like a standing up and I just noticed that I was,
I was looking around more and,
and I looked out in the ocean.
I noticed there that day there were these dolphins jumping in the ocean and,
and I went down to Marina del to my turnaround point and um,
oh no,
actually it was when the,
the breakers at Marina del Rey,
there was a penguin
flying above me.
I was like,
no way.
Looked up.
I was like,
Hey,
I'm paying.
And he shit in my mouth.
Was it a penguin or a Pelican?
Oh,
sorry.
Pelican.
We just penguin above my head.
I was like,
what did you take before your ride?
So you see it a Pelican [inaudible] Pelican shit in your mouth.
What was it?
That's incredible accuracy.
Was that from like how far away was it a you like 20 feet up?
Wow.
I Dunno if he was accurate or I was,
you know.
Yeah
it is.
I had such a nice time.
It was just purely pleasant.
There was no red face,
there was no huffing and puffing.
I was just cycling.
It was nice and when I got back to my usual stopping place,
I looked at my watch and it said 45 minutes and I was like,
no way.
How the hell could that have been 45 minutes as compared to my usual 43 it's
like there's no way.
But yeah,
it was right 45 minutes and that was like a profound lesson that I think changed
the way I've approached my life ever since is because I realized that I guess
you know what percentage of that huffing and puffing then we could do the math
and whatever.
I would a 93 point something present of my huffing and puffing and all that red
face and all that stress was only for an extra two minutes.
It was basically for nothing.
I mean,
you know,
of course we're not talking about me competing in something where the huffing
and puffing might've been worth it.
But for life,
I think of all of this optimization and getting the maximum dollar out of
everything in the maximum amount of every second to the maximum amount of every
minute.
And I think I just take this approach now of going like,
oh,
or you could just take the lesson,
take most of that lesson and apply it and be effective and be happy,
but you don't need to stress about any of this stuff.
And so honestly that's been my approach ever since I do things,
but I stopped it before anything gets stressful.
Is there any particular way that you remind yourself of that given a lifetime of
hard charging a fee I would fund.
I do find that I sometimes lose track of that type of truth,
which I think is a truth in almost every aspect of the endeavors that I partake
in,
at least.
Are there any particular ways that you remind yourself of that or keep it
present for you?
I think it's just noticing the pain.
I luckily I live in a world where there's more psychic pain than physical pain.
Right?
So you have to notice the psychic pain that you're feeling,
um,
of whether it's doing things you don't want to be doing and feeling the pain and
regret of that or the frustration.
Just when you notice this internal,
that always,
that's my cue that I treat that like physical pain of like,
what am I doing,
what I need to stop doing that thing that hurts.
What is that?
And it usually means that I'm just pushing too hard or doing things that I don't
really want to be doing because I was asking the wrong questions and uh,
following the wrong.
Yeah.
Following the wrong path,
the wrong outcome.
No.
Rewinding the clock a little bit.
Uh,
1998.
How did CD baby come to be?
Yeah.
Um,
it was,
I was really just selling my own CD on my band's website.
I was just,
I had a band called hit me and I had this CD that was being played on radio
stations across the country.
I think I was on 350 college radio stations across America,
but the only way to buy it was to mail a check or money order to my address.
You know,
this is before the average person could get any ecommerce online because there
was no paypal.
I guess I could have put it up on Ebay or something.
Right,
but that was like the only way you could sell your CD online as an independent
musician.
There was just nobody anywhere that would sell it for you.
There were a big online record stores at the time.
There was a music boulevard.com and CD now.com.
I think Amazon bought them both,
but the only way to get into their system was to go through the major labels,
basically to get a major label record deal and then be in the major label
distribution system.
And then you would appear on CD now.com right.
So I thought,
okay,
this is,
this is just a horrible convoluted thing.
Like it should be dead simple to just put your stuff online,
have a buy now button and ship it to the person that buys it.
It shouldn't need to be that complicated.
So I did the research and I did the work and I went and got myself a credit card
merchant account,
which is like $1,000 in setup fees.
They actually had to send an inspector out to my location to make sure I was a
valid business.
I think I even had to incorporate to make them happy.
I set up a separate bank account,
uh,
did all of this red tape,
a lot of paperwork,
thousand dollars instead of fees.
Uh,
but after three months I had a credit card merchant account and then I had to
figure out how to make a buy now button on my website.
And that was also hard,
you know,
it was,
I had to buy a book on Cgi bin Perl Scripts and copy the example from the book
on how to make a buy now button.
And,
but after three months of hard work,
I did it like my band's website had a buy now button that was like,
wow,
look at that.
And so my friends in the New York City music scene,
like my fellow musicians,
uh,
said,
whoa dude.
Like,
do you think you could sell my CD through that thing?
I said,
you mean on my band's website?
They said,
yeah,
if you don't mind.
I said,
yeah,
sure,
why not?
So it was like a favor to my friend Marco.
Um,
actually here's a little tidbit of information.
Marco,
who I just knew as a musician,
Marco [inaudible].
I knew him as a cool musician in New York City.
He was technically the guy that gave me the idea for CD baby.
Later I found out that he's the son of the prime minister of Finland.
Uh,
and it was like all in the news and I had no idea,
but Marco,
thank you.
He's the one that asked me if I could sell his CD,
uh,
through my band's website.
And so I did.
And then,
you know,
I started getting calls like,
hey man,
my friend Marco said,
or you could sell my CD through your website.
Said,
yeah,
no problem.
Friend of Marco's as a friend of mine and it just,
it grew by request and yeah,
which is,
which kind of led me to the belief that,
you know,
when people ask me how to,
how do I grow my business,
I've got this business idea.
Basically I'm trying to push it onto the world.
How do I push my idea into the world?
I have no idea.
I have no advice for those people because I've only ever worked on like the pull
method where people ask me to do things for them.
And I say yes.
So CD baby just happened because all of my musician friends or asking me to sell
their CD on my band's website and then I just eventually there were so many that
I just took them off of my band's site and put them onto their own site.
And that was CD baby.com.
Of your projects that have done well,
what percentage have come from scratching your own itch?
Allah CD baby,
uh,
have,
are any of the projects that have gained traction projects that you've thought
of sending to a market that didn't include you?
Actually,
after that first one,
I mean,
yes,
I built a thing to sell my own CD,
but um,
actually all of them were scratching other people's itches.
I don't want to get to a,
I don't want to picture that.
Um,
so,
uh,
like for example,
um,
shortly after that,
I already had a UPC barcode thing.
The way it used to work with that.
Um,
to get a barcode on your album,
you had to pay like,
I don't know,
$400 to the Universal Code Council in order to get a six digit prefix,
which then let you assign the next five digits,
which meant 100,000 products underneath your barcode.
Um,
product id or something like that.
So a lot of musicians in the independent music world wanted to have a UPC
barcode for their album that would let them sell it in physical retail stores.
And a lot of physical retail stores wouldn't let you sell something unless it
had a UPC barcode.
But they didn't want to all have to pay the $400 to get a company account.
But I already had a company account and so I just let a lot of musicians know,
like,
if you ever need a barcode,
let me know.
I can get one for you.
So enough people started taking me up on this that I decided to charge 20 bucks
for it because it would take me some time to assign them an id and then generate
the eps or tiff graphic file to be included in their album artwork.
And eventually I automated it.
Point is um,
100,000 barcodes were assigned at $20 each.
That's what I charged for the service.
It was like $2 million I made for this $400 set up fee for getting a universal
code council account.
So you could say that I was scratching my itch,
but really that it was more,
I think of it as the co op business model,
let's freeze.
It was responding to demand instead of trying to create demand.
Is that yes.
I've never tried to create demand.
I've never done that.
I don't know how.
I've only basic Li answered the calls for help.
Right.
And it's usually using this,
what I call the Co op business model,
which is I've already got something other people could use it.
I'm happy to share it.
I'll just charge a little something to help pay for my time and resources so
that we can all share this resource that I've already got.
So I love,
this is a,
I think a great example of spotting something small,
perhaps looking at a situation that many,
many other people had been presented with and spotting something interesting in
this case,
an opportunity.
And I want to highlight one other example,
which is an email that you wrote and I'm going to,
I'm going to just read a little bit here.
So this is,
uh,
this is from some of your writing.
When you make a business,
you're making a little world where you control the laws.
It doesn't matter how things are done everywhere else and your little world,
you can make it like it should be.
And I know you're better at reading this stuff,
but I'm just going to just because I have it right in front of me.
Uh,
when I first built CD baby,
every order had an automated email that let the customer know when the CD was
actually shipped.
And of course,
this is Tim speaking.
Now.
Uh,
everyone's seen these.
They tend to be very plain Jane,
very generic,
very boring.
At first it was just the normal.
This is back to your writing your orders ship today.
Please let us know if it doesn't arrive.
Thank you for your business.
A few months later,
I felt it was very incongruent with my mission to help people smile.
I knew I could do better,
so I took 20 minutes and wrote this goofy little thing.
This is the email that would go out to folks.
Your CD has been gently taken from our CD baby shelves with sterilized
contamination,
free gloves and placed onto a satin pillow.
A team of 50 employees inspected your CD and polished it to make sure it was the
best possible condition.
Before mailing.
Our packing specialist from Japan lit a candle and a hush fell over the crowd as
he put your CD into the finest gold line box that money can buy.
We all had a wonderful celebration afterwards and the whole Party marched down
the street to the post office where the entire town of Portland waved bon voyage
to your package on its way.
To you in our private CD baby jet on this day,
Friday,
June 6th.
I hope that you had a wonderful time shopping at CD baby.
We sure did.
Your pictures on our wall as customer of the year,
we're all exhausted,
but can't wait for you to come back to CD baby dot cop two exclamation points.
Uh,
so
that 20 minutes,
what happened after you put that together?
Okay,
well people would get it and reply back like who ever replies back to an
automated shipping email,
right?
Um,
whoever replies back to Amazon saying,
wow guys,
thank you so much.
But the fact that this little quirky email had so much personality for one,
it let them know like there's real people here.
And so customers will often reply back saying,
you guys are hilarious.
That was the weirdest thing ever.
That's awesome.
But more importantly,
people started sharing it.
They would forward it to,
to all of their friends.
Like you guys have to see this.
And people who had blogs would post it on their blogs,
even just their lean,
a little blog spot or wordpress or whatever blog.
Um,
so now if you take any of those sentences from that email and you put it into
quotation marks and a search for it on Google,
you'll find literally thousands of blogs have pasted my,
a confirmation email onto their blogs.
And I think about this when a young entrepreneurs ask me like,
how can I get traction from it?
My idea,
how can I get,
how can I get word of mouth and buzz happening?
I think you can read business books and,
and,
um,
try to do these very serious,
you know,
furrowed brow analytical approaches to this.
Or sometimes it's just these cute little colorful things that you do that set
you apart from the rest that make you remarkable.
Make people remark on you about you.
So yeah,
I think thousands of people heard about CD baby because of that one little silly
email.
And I think it a comparable might be Zappos for instance,
and their customer service.
And what was the anecdote that got spread around?
The anecdote was you could call up Zappos for anything,
even if it was unrelated to the product,
you could call them up and say,
yes,
I'm looking at the website,
but I'd actually really like a pizza delivered to my house and they would figure
out how to do it.
And on the serious analytical side,
you say,
oh my God,
that's such a waste of human and capital resources.
And can you imagine if everybody called to order pizza,
which of course the scale is never going to happen ever.
And uh,
they got,
so,
I mean,
probably millions of dollars of free publicity just by making that.
Okay.
And like how long did that take?
Not long at all.
Uh,
plus you know what,
man,
it's,
I don't mean to sound like new agey or whatever,
but it's the right thing to do for the world.
Right?
It's like,
just put aside the numbers for a bit.
It's the right thing to do.
It's cool.
It makes people happier.
It makes the people working.
They're happier,
which makes them more into the whole feeling of what they're doing.
There's so much more to a business than just the money.
Yeah.
So,
so tell me about,
I remember reading about this,
but I think we might've talked about it at one point,
which was when people would call CD baby trying to offer you financing.
How did those go?
Well,
you remember I started CD baby like the end of [inaudible] 97 beginning of
[inaudible] 98 so it was the first.com boom.
And so much money was flying around and everybody was trying to push
money@everyonewhohada.com on their domain name or had anything going on.
So of course me with an actual like profitable running business,
that was really the only game in town by the way.
Like back when I started it,
if you were a musician that wanted to sell your music online,
there was a guy named Derek in New York that could do it for you.
And that was it.
There were no other businesses that will do it.
They,
some showed up like a year or two later.
But at first I had no competition at all.
I was it.
So yeah,
it's tons of money was a shoved my direction and I entertained the first few
calls and they said,
you know,
we want to invest in your company so well,
why?
They said so you can grow it faster.
I said,
but I don't want to grow it faster.
well,
you know,
don't you want to scale or get your get more resources?
I said,
no,
I,
I have all the resources I need.
Like I'm good.
Like I was profitable,
you know,
since the first month in business because my startup costs were a $495 is what
it costs me to start the business and get it running.
It took me six days to build the site and get it up and running.
And it was profitable in the second month of business when I sold over a $4 of
cds that second month in business that was profitable ever since.
And uh,
I just didn't need the money.
And so yeah,
people kept offering and they would waive these big dreams in my face thinking
it was going to distract them or entice me.
But it just didn't,
and I remember,
Oh I doubt you remember mp3.com was a big deal in like 1999 through 2002 or so.
They were like the big daddy of independent streaming music online and
downloads.
And so they had all,
I think,
yeah,
they had an IPO,
they were public and mp3.com was interested in buying CD baby.
And they asked what my price would be and I said,
just not interested in selling.
And they said,
come on,
everybody's got their price.
I said,
no,
I'm not interested.
I'm having fun.
They said,
come on,
even billions of dollars.
And I said,
what are you Carl Sagan?
No,
I don't want to sell.
Um,
there's just nothing in it for me.
I'm enjoying what I'm doing.
I don't need the money.
So after that point,
like after the first year or two,
I just taught my customer service people.
Like if you get any calls from investors or I,
um,
whatever VC firms or any of that,
please just tell them no.
Like,
don't even send them my way.
I'm just,
we're just not interested.
So,
yeah,
that lasted for 10 years.
And how did you,
uh,
how did you develop that relationship with money?
Is that something from your parents?
Is that,
and I'm going to ask a very personal question.
I'll send sudden you can feel free to not answer it,
but why did your family,
why did,
why were none of your family members at your wedding?
Oh,
sorry.
They were too,
oh,
sorry.
When I say Nice to free guess I meant,
yeah.
Okay.
All right.
No,
no,
no.
Now that I've checked that,
okay,
this is what was in the back of my mind.
How did you develop this relationship with money where you would say no like
that for 10 years?
Because that's not what most people would do
because I had enough at,
because I absolutely,
you know what,
it's,
it's a bit of a trick reason because in the early days I still considered CD
baby to be a bit of a distraction because you remember I was making my living as
a professional musician,
which was my original goal and dream.
So I was living my dream like I was,
I was touring,
playing on people's records,
producing people's records.
Um,
I played about 500 colleges in the northeast.
I was making good money as a professional musician.
Like that's what I really wanted to do.
And this little CD baby thing was just like a favor I was doing to my,
for my friends to kind of give back to the community.
Right?
So as it grew,
well I didn't want it to,
to grow,
um,
because yeah,
it was taking me away from my music,
which is my real love.
It's making the music,
not selling other people's music.
So there was this moment when I kind of realized I think I've created a
business.
Oh well I might as well make it something awesome.
Meaning,
um,
I want to make it like a utopian dream come true from a musician's point of
view.
And I spent a night brainstorming,
like what would a real like dream come true from a physician's point of view
look like?
And I don't know if this will make sense to your listeners,
but let's just find out is did that it was going against everything.
That was the unfortunate way that the music distribution world worked at the
time.
So it's like number one,
I want to be paid every week.
Number two,
I want to know the full name and address of everybody that buys my music.
Um,
number three,
you'll never kick me out for not selling enough because that was a big problem
in the traditional music distribution world as you were given a window of time.
Kind of like,
like physical books are still are,
you have to prove yourself in a window of time.
They'll put you into the bookstore.
If it doesn't sell well,
you're,
you're yanked out to make room on the shelf for other stuff.
And then number four,
no paid placement because it never felt fair that,
uh,
people could come in and buy up the front page to get a unequal footing.
Right?
So that was like my utopian ideal for how this would work.
The reason I'm telling you this is that to set the tone that like I wasn't
trying to make money,
I already had enough money that I had made,
you know,
gigging and touring and all that stuff.
I already had money.
So this was a thing I was doing to give back to the community to create
something that needed to exist kind of artistically,
or just almost like a community service kind of thing.
So,
so that was the original DNA of this thing.
And you know,
from what we know about DNA,
it helps decide how,
what things grow into.
Right?
So this was the DNA.
So then as it grew and then it became really profitable and I was making,
I don't know,
$100,000 a month doing this thing,
and I had all my bills paid off.
There was nothing I wanted to buy.
So if somebody from California contacted me saying they wanted to give me lots
of money to take a big chunk of my business and help turn it,
you know,
big,
we think you could do an IPO.
Uh,
I would just sneer like,
uh,
no,
that sounds awful.
I don't want that life.
I'm,
I'm enjoying being fully in control here and doing things for the right reasons.
Doing things for my musician friends to make them happy,
make the customers happy,
make the musicians happy,
like all good.
Um,
what was the business model in the very beginning?
it was only two numbers actually.
There's,
there's a cute story.
Most of us,
you know,
when we start charging money for the first time for our services or our goods,
we don't know what to charge.
Right?
So for Marco,
my first friend that asked me to do this,
and maybe the next 10 or 15 friends that came after I was charging nothing,
I was just doing this as a free favor.
This was my community service.
And I,
once I realized like total strangers who were sending me their music,
that's not all right.
I bet her charge something,
but I don't know what to charge.
So I was living in Woodstock,
New York at the time and there was a cute,
tiny little record store in town that sold consignment cds.
On the counter of local musicians.
So I walked in there one day and I said,
hey,
um,
how does it work if I want to sell my CD here?
And she said,
well,
you set the selling price,
whatever you want,
we just keep a flat $4 per CD sold and then just come by every week and we'll
pay you.
So I went home to my new website that night and I wrote,
you set your selling price it whatever you want.
We just keep a flat $4 per CD sold and we'll pay you every week.
And then I realized that it took about 45 minutes of time for me to set up a new
album into the system because I had to lay the album art on the scanner and
Photoshop it and crop it and then fix the musicians,
have spelling mistakes in their own bio and all that kind of stuff.
Uh,
that took about 45 minutes of work per album.
So it shows you what I was valuing my time at those days that I thought 45
minutes of my time,
that's worth about 25 bucks.
So I'll charge a $25 set up fee to sign up for this thing.
And then at the last minute I thought,
wait a second.
In my mind,
25 and 35 they hold that they're in the same like brain cell in my head,
25 and 35 those numbers don't feel very different when it comes to cost.
You know like $10 is different and $50 is different,
but 25 35 that occupies the same space in the mind.
So you know what?
I'm going to make it 35 that will let me give anyone a discount anytime they
ask.
You know,
even if somebody's on the phone and upset,
I'll say,
you know what,
let me give you a discount.
So I added in that little buffer so I could give people a discount,
which they love.
So yeah,
$35 set up fee,
$4 per CD sold,
and the Tim for the next 10 years,
that was it.
That was my entire business model,
which was generated in five minutes by walking down to the local record store
and asking what they do.
I love that story and simplicity because I think there is an infatuation of
fetishizing,
of pivoting in the tech startup world that has infected many other types of
entrepreneurship where people think like,
Oh,
if we're not pivoting,
I'm not doing something correctly.
I should change my business model in my entire customer base every two months
and I don't view that as a virtue.
Yes,
there are times to change if something isn't working,
but if you don't take the time upfront to think about that and then you're
constantly chasing the latest sort of fad or whatever appears on the cover of a
tech crunch or ink magazine or something like that.
It's a,
it's a recipe for failure for most people.
I mean there's a huge survivorship bias.
I'm just going to rant for a second.
There's a huge survivorship bias that I think is important to realize if you're
hoping to become an entrepreneur or are an entrepreneur.
If you're only reading the cover stories,
you're only getting
the happy success stories.
And you know,
for that reason also I think it's,
it's dangerous to idolize people who bet the farm and just happened to pull it
off because those are the people who are going to be written about much like if
you open a Barron's and you look at all of these mutual funds with these
spectacular records,
well maybe they just got lucky and all the other ones can't afford to buy ads
because they're no longer in existence.
And um,
so I think it's,
it's very similar that the,
uh,
the,
the one of the essays that you're best known for is a hell yeah or no.
And this has been extremely important for me to consistently reread a or
listened to.
How did it come about?
And then what is the,
what is the gist of that?
There was a music conference in Australia that I had told my friend I would go
with her to.
It wasn't even like the conference themselves were really expecting me.
It was my,
my friend Arielle Hyatt is one of the best publicist I know.
And She was speaking at that conference and asked if I would come with her as
like a Co presenter in her mentor session or something.
So I had said yes like six months before.
Yeah,
sure.
Australia living in New York City and like,
yeah,
sure.
Um,
and then once it came close and it was like time to book the ticket,
I was like,
Eh,
I don't really want to go to Australia right now.
I'm busy with other stuff.
And it was actually my friend amber,
Rue Barth,
who's a brilliant musician.
I was on the phone with her and kind of lamenting about this and she's the one
that pointed out,
she said,
it sounds like you know from where you're at,
you're decision is not between yes and no.
You need to figure out whether you're feeling like,
fuck yeah or no.
And I said,
yeah,
that's,
that's really what it comes down to,
right?
Because the idea is if you're feeling anything less than like,
Oh hell yeah,
I would love to do that.
Oh my God,
that would be amazing.
If you're feeling anything less than that than just say no because most of us
say yes to too much stuff and then we let these little mediocre things fill our
lives.
And so the problem is when that occasional big,
oh my God,
hell yeah,
thing comes along.
You don't have enough time to to give it the attention that you should because
you've said yes to too much other little halfass kind of stuff.
Right.
So once I started applying this,
uh,
my life just opened up because it just meant I just said no,
no,
no to almost everything.
But then when the occasional thing came up that I was really lucky,
know what that would be awesome.
Then suddenly I had all the time in the world and you know,
people say this,
I'm sure you know,
every time people contact you,
every time people come tacked me,
they say,
you know,
look,
I know you must be incredibly busy.
And I always think like,
no,
I'm not because because I'm in control of my time,
I'm on top of it.
Busy to me seems to imply like out of control,
you know like,
Oh my God,
I'm so busy,
I don't have any time for this shit.
To me that sounds like a person who's got no control of their life.
Yeah,
no,
no control and unclear priorities.
Yes.
So you asked how it's applying in my life that still just on the little tiny day
to day level,
even personal things,
God,
even even people you need to even,
you know,
I'm a,
as I'm dating,
you have to do the hell yeah or no approach or people ask you to go to events or
caught even,
you know,
even people asking to do a phone call or anything.
I think,
you know,
am I really excited about that?
And you know,
almost every time the answer is no.
So I say no to almost everything and then occasionally something will come up.
Even a little surprise will be dropped in my lap.
Like this thing that happened just a two months ago called the the now,
now,
now project,
which we don't even really need to talk about.
The details don't matter so much,
but it was just something that popped up that seemed really interesting and
people really wanted.
And luckily because I say no to almost everything,
I had the time in my life to make it flourish.
So for the last like six weeks,
all I did full time,
like 12 hours a day with suddenly work on this brand new thing that showed up
because I could,
you know,
so that's to me the,
the lovely a result of taking the hell yeah or no approach to life.
Where can people learn more and check out the no,
no,
no project.
And also I should note in advance that for,
for folks listening,
um,
we will also include links to anything we've mentioned in the show notes,
which will be@fourhourworkweek.com forward slash Derek all spelled out.
Uh,
but where can people find more about no,
no,
it's um,
if you go to now,
now,
now.com,
you'll find more about that.
It was just in short,
I noticed that everybody has,
uh,
an about page on their site and people have a contact page on their site.
But usually whenever I'm looking at somebody's personal site,
even yours,
w a big thing I often wonder is like,
I wonder what he's up to right now.
Like working on kind of stuff and Twitter and Facebook don't answer that.
You know,
you can see somebody's stream of stuff,
but it just kind of says like,
okay,
here's what I had for dinner last night.
You know,
here's something in the news I'm mad about,
or here's a cute thing I'm sharing,
but it doesn't really tell me like,
how are you,
you know,
like if you and I haven't talked to her a year,
like,
what's up?
How you doing?
How you doing,
what you're working on.
So to me,
the whole idea of a now page on your site,
it's just a general,
like,
here's what's up with me now.
So,
uh,
I just had one of those on my site.
Uh,
I had a now page and then,
uh,
a guy named Gregory Brown saw it,
liked it.
He put one on his site and all I did was just retweet him when he told me and I
said,
cool,
I wish everybody had a now page.
And like within a few hours there are eight more people had a now page and then
within a month
the 550 people had a now page on their website.
So I just put together now,
now,
now.com.
It's just like kind of a cute collection of people who have a now page on their
website.
Yeah.
Anyway,
but you know what I mean?
The point is the details don't matter.
But like I'm so glad I had the time to do that.
And it was only because I say no to almost everything that I was able to just
throw myself into this project and build this new thing on,
uh,
on,
women catch the momentum.
So I am reading a section of this,
this blog posts that I wrote about you and you're the best email you ever wrote
with the,
the Japanese boxing specialist and so on.
And one of the paragraphs that I put here for those people interested,
it's just the most successful email I ever wrote,
but a,
it's everywhere online and it reads stranger still at its largest.
Derek spent roughly four hours on CD baby every six months.
He had systematized everything to run without them.
And feel free to correct that if it,
if it needs to be corrected,
but what,
assuming that's roughly true,
what were some of the most important decisions or realizations that made that
possible?
Hmm.
I love the timing for when I read four hour work week because it was actually
just after I had done this like complete delegation of everything.
Um,
that it was feeling the pain from everything having to go through me all right.
Like it was,
it was my business,
right?
100%,
no investors,
no nothing.
It was me.
And so I hired people to help me.
It was all me,
me,
me.
So four years into it,
it was growing.
It was really taking off.
I had 20 employees,
but still almost everything went through me and it made my day kind of miserable
because I'm a
real like introverted focused kind of person.
I love to just sit down for 12 hours and do one thing without distraction.
You're an I n t j a Myers Briggs.
Yep.
Are you I'm a hundred percent IMTJ.
Yup.
Um,
it's so
I hated going to the office and being distracted every five minutes with my
employees asking me questions.
So that's what I just felt such pain about this.
Like,
hey that,
that I really literally meant I booked a flight to [inaudible] I believe and I
was going to move to quiet and not give my employees my phone number and
literally move.
I don't mean like take a vacation.
I mean like I am now going to be running,
see,
or I'm to be the owner of CD baby on a little island in Hawaiian.
You guys just figure out your own damn problems cause I was just,
I was just having so much psychic pain about this.
But then luckily with lovely coincidence that night that I booked the flight to
Hawaii,
um,
I watched the movie vanilla sky and in Vanilla Sky Tom Cruise,
it's like the owner of this big publishing company,
but he gets all caught up with these crazy women and um,
gets too overwhelmed with his life and focusing on his own happiness and our,
or unhappiness and all that.
And pretty soon his,
his company has just wrestled away from him.
And I thought,
oh,
I don't want that to happen.
Like,
I don't want to just plug my ears closed.
My eyes are runaway and have my company taken away from me.
Um,
I need to give this,
I need to deal with my problems instead of running from them.
So I canceled the trip to Hawaii and went into work the next day and decided to
fix this thing.
So then the next time somebody asks me a question,
I'd gathered everybody around.
I said,
okay,
everybody.
Tracy just asked me,
you know,
um,
Derek,
what do we do when a guy on the phone says he wants a refund?
You know,
I said,
okay,
everybody stop working.
Everybody gather round.
Okay,
Tracy asked what we do.
If somebody wants a refund,
here's,
here's not only what we do,
but here's why.
Here's my philosophy.
Whenever anybody wants a refund,
mom,
all,
we should always give it to them.
And I would just explain not just the what to do,
but the why.
It was constantly communicating the philosophy.
Um,
to get to the core of it.
And I think you mentioned this in back and four hour work week,
there's almost nothing that really has to be you.
Like you can almost get kind of AI and figure out how your brain works,
how your decision making process works and just teach it to other people so that
other people can do it.
And um,
yeah,
that's what I did for every single thing that ever came my way.
I would gather everybody around,
explain the philosophy behind it,
why we do things this way,
why I'm about to say what I'm about to say.
And now here's what I think we should do.
Do you understand why now please write it down.
But it was also important that I taught it to multiple people,
not just one,
and had them write it down.
And then the cool thing is I wasn't doing the hiring anymore,
the company,
I had taught other people how to do the hiring.
So soon my employees were doing the hiring and then they were teaching new
people how to do this thing from the book.
And Yeah,
so by,
let's see.
So that really started four years into the company who was six months of
difficult work to really make myself unnecessary.
But then my girlfriend at the time decided to go to film school in La,
so decided to follow her down there.
So I moved down to La to be with her,
which was a nice symbolic way to let the company know like you're on your own.
I'm still the owner.
And in fact,
so there,
there's one little caveat to the thing where you said that I was working on a CD
baby for four hours a year or whatever you said.
Yeah,
four,
I'm sorry,
six months is that,
that's how much time I spent doing this stuff.
I didn't want to be doing right.
The monotony,
the bureaucracy stuff that I had reduced down to almost nothing like a few
minutes a week,
but what I was doing from 7:00 AM to midnight every single day was programming
like the future of CD baby.
Uh,
and that's just the stuff that I loved doing.
So it was just,
it was about making my life the way I wanted it to be.
Working on the stuff that I wanted to be working on and not doing the stuff I
didn't,
which I'm glad you brought that up because I want to clarify something that is a
common misconception related understandably to the title of the four hour work
week and at the end there's,
I is the,
it's like the single largest blessing and curse that is going to follow me for
the rest of my life,
but it's a catchy title.
Yes.
I tested it on Google ad words.
Had a great conversion rate.
That's why it's that instead of something stupid like lifestyle hustling or the
chameleon blah,
blah,
blah.
I had a bunch of terrible titles that one performed best,
but the objective is not to be idle.
The objective is to control this non renewable resource called time so that you
can allocate it to the things you most want to be doing.
So I don't have,
in other words,
a trouble with heart.
I don't have a problem with hard work as long as it is applied to the right
things that are determined with some degree of self awareness and forethought or
planning.
Uh,
so that's,
that's sort of PSA.
Not for you Derek.
Cause you,
I read the book but for,
but for every like Dick who stands up at a public Q and a and goes routes him,
I just wanted to ask,
do you look for it?
I was a week
and this one I'm like turn into one of the fantastic four and punch him in the
neck from 300 feet away.
But for everyone who is,
it is,
um,
maybe inclined to stand up and ask that question.
There's the answer.
Read the book.
Um,
and uh,
I,
I bumped into somebody recently.
You mentioned this book with the,
I guess frequently asked questions and he was like,
you should just make,
cause I told them,
I was like,
you know,
I try to be really patient.
I try to spend a lot of time answering people's questions when they have them.
But it's so clear that most people asking questions have not read the fucking
book.
And there'll be like,
can I eat bananas on the slow Carb Diet?
You know,
can I key in La after chocolate concert on this low carb diet?
And I'm just like,
fuck,
if you have to ask,
the answer is no,
and you clearly didn't read it.
And he's like,
you should just make a,
you should just have tee shirts that say,
what was it?
R T F m yeah.
Read the fucking read the fucking manual.
But a alas Allah called.
Cut that,
that scree a little short.
The book itself.
I want to get a dig into some specifics with this,
this manual,
uh,
this rule book.
When you had multiple people write it down,
how did you then put together a resource that could be shared with new hires?
And on,
actually I think we,
we'd put it on a,
um,
put it on a wiki inside,
but honestly most of it was just word of mouth kind of legend inside.
Like they were a few internal stories,
kind of like the,
the Zappos pizza story you just told.
The one I always heard was um,
Nordstrom's,
uh,
that there's some legend about guy buys a shirt from Sears and it gets like
burnt up in a fire and he goes to Nordstrom's to return it and they give him his
money back.
Like they have like such a liberal return policy to,
they'll even let you return burnt stuff from another store.
And so a legend like that will travel down and it,
it carries the philosophy inside of it.
So it's almost like us little story like that can replace 20 pages of an
employee handbook.
Totally agree.
Yeah.
It's an aphorism or it's a store.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
fable.
So there were quite a few of those inside CD baby,
especially for the early people would see the decisions that I had made and the
people that I had given all their money back in case anything went wrong or just
you just talking to me in the conversations and getting my philosophies and the
early employees at CD baby really got it.
And then they would spread it to the new people
all knee.
If we flip from book writing to book reading,
uh,
you have a page on your site,
sivers.org forward slash book.
I'll link to it in the show notes.
I think it's book,
correct me if the URL is it,
you have notes on more than 200 bucks.
You appear to be a voracious reader.
How do you select the books you read and how do you read them?
Okay.
I select,
I really,
I let,
um,
usually large numbers of people decide meaning like lots and lots of five star
reviews on Amazon,
right?
Um,
occasionally somebody that I really respect and that knows me will tell me,
you need to read this book.
And even if it's had no reviews on Amazon,
I'll just trust them.
But for the most part I tend to go for things that I've seen,
lots of rave reviews.
Then I browse through the description on Amazon,
then I look at the review,
actually read the reviews people have said,
and it really sounds like something,
okay,
this sounds worth my time because I don't read fast and I don't,
I don't try to read fast.
I like to sit and ponder as I'm reading.
So when I'm committing to a book,
yeah,
that's,
that's 20 or 30 hours often.
Um,
so I don't take it lightly.
So yeah,
I tend to go with lots of Amazon reviews,
but then I also give up quickly.
So if like chapter three,
if by chapter three,
I'm not really into it,
I just ditch it and you don't even see those on my side.
So I've ditched almost as many as you see there.
Um,
and I just don't write them up.
I just delete them on the kindle and move on.
So,
but here's interesting thing is,
okay,
there's a couple of doing things.
So years ago,
actually it was around 2007 when I first read four hour workweek,
I was living in London.
Even though CD baby you would still like up and running back in Portland,
Oregon.
A just cause I want to do experience the world.
I was living in London at the time and I actually,
you know,
it's funny,
I don't know if I ever told you this cute story.
It was my friend Arielle Hyatt who I mentioned earlier that told me about you
and the four hour work week,
but she told me a little fable about you.
So I can't remember if I ever confirmed this with you.
She we'll find out right now.
I think at the time she was going to some kind of like mastermind seminar by one
of those like how to be a millionaire kind of guys.
And apparently,
uh,
you know like five or six of those how to be a millionaire kind of guys held
some big mastermind thing in Hawaii or something.
And you were supposed to be there and you didn't show.
And I think like Robert Kiyosaki and people like that were there and you were
supposed to be there,
but you didn't show up until the third day where you showed up like covered in
mud because you had just on a whim decided to try sleeping in a tree or
something like that.
The legend goes and uh,
she told me about the four hour workweek and,
but basically like in this context of his guy,
Tim,
that doesn't give a fuck about convention.
And it totally sounds like you're kinda guy that a is doing things the way that
you do it cause you don't give a fuck about convention either and you should
read his book.
So that was like,
yeah,
I think it wasn't even available in England at the time.
I had to go actually I think the first time I got four hour work week with
something like illegal pdf download of it off of bit torrent.
That's how it happens a lot.
I'd say that's,
that story I believe is true.
So I remember this particular,
uh,
this particular event in Hawaii around the time that the book came out,
or maybe a year afterwards within the year following publication.
And I remember going to Hawaii and realizing that I wanted to explore Hawaii as
opposed to sitting in the conference room.
So I rented a car and ended up finding a bed and breakfast where this house was
built in the trees.
This is still totally issue and uh,
but it wasn't available or it wasn't on the market.
And the caretaker ended up being this very attractive woman.
And I said,
well,
is there anything that I can do because to be able to sleep in this tree house,
because I'm really obsessed with this idea and it looks like Jurassic Park here
with these sort of prehistoric looking plants,
I'll even,
and she had some like dig a ditch that needed to be dug or something.
And so I did that and did all this manual labor.
Then I ended up being able to stay in the,
in the tree house.
And I think that,
uh,
it was on the Hana,
I want to say the Hana highway,
if I'm getting that right,
just spectacular.
I think it was in,
and so I did show up to the event late,
like a tank top and these absurdly now even to be embarrassing like European
short shorts,
I don't know why.
And uh,
yeah,
that's,
that's a true story.
So it is true and so can for can the confirmed,
uh,
it's so funny.
Uh,
I forget what tangent we are on.
Oh,
we were talking about,
we were talking about uh,
how you read books.
Ah,
okay.
So right around that time I,
I had been reading books for agency for years and people often ask about like
mentorship and did you have any mentors?
And I say,
well,
don't books are my mentor.
It's like books guide almost everything I do.
Like the stuff I've learned from books totally guides my life.
Um,
so I realized though that I would love a book while reading it and maybe it
would still echo with me for a few weeks after.
But you know,
two years later I couldn't even remember if I had read it or not.
And I thought that's really a shame.
Like I remember at the time,
that book meant a lot to me.
Why is it now two years later,
I've forgotten everything.
I said,
no,
that's not good.
So what I started doing in 2007 is every book I read,
I would keep a pen in hand and I would underline my favorite sentences.
Um,
circle my favorite paragraphs,
write notes in the margins.
And then after I was done reading the book,
I would put aside like two hours to open up a blank text file and type out
everything into a plain text file
so that I could,
knowing that plain text files are about the most permanent,
long last date format there can be.
They will work on everything.
You can read them on phones or new devices we haven't even thought of yet.
We'll always be able to read plain text files.
So I started doing this for every book I read and then I would review my notes
later.
So every time I'm say just eating breakfast or something for 10 minutes,
I'll pull up one of the notes from a previous book I read and just kind of re
review it.
Sometimes kind of stop,
take a sentence.
That means a lot to me right now.
Open up my diary and write about that for a while.
Like really internalize.
Basically I wanted to memorize every lesson I had learned in every one of these
books.
So that's what I started doing.
I even started putting them into the space repetition systems and that didn't
really work out too well because I wasn't sure how to formulate that knowledge
into a Q and a flashcard to kind of format you're using stuff,
super memo or something like that.
Exactly.
Aki.
So,
um,
uncased I'd know for people means rote memorization and Japanese.
Oh really?
A and k.
I.
M sorry to interrupt.
So,
so it wasn't until say 2010 that I realized that I just had all of these lovely
book notes hidden on my hard drive just for my eyes only.
And I thought,
you know,
why don't I just put them on my website?
If the publishers tell me to take them down,
I will.
But maybe it's of use to people.
So yeah,
sivers.org/book what you're seeing is all of my detailed book notes I've taken
since 2007.
If you were to,
this may be a very difficult question to answer,
but to suggest five to start with,
um,
or so,
I mean,
I'm just throwing out a random number,
but if you were to suggest some books to start with@sivers.org forward slash
book
and this is,
by the way,
this is not a set up for my own book.
This is
God.
Wouldn't that be TV
first?
The four hour workweek second.
See rule number one?
No.
So,
uh,
the,
I've actually already answered the question for you because,
uh,
once I posted them on my site,
I realized I should give them like a one to 10 rating because I knew this is
the,
the next question people are going to ask is,
well,
which ones would you recommend?
So,
uh,
I give every book of one to 10 rating and it's when you go to sivers.org/book,
it's already sorted for you with my top recommendations up top.
And I think it's,
you know what,
I hadn't told you this either.
Um,
back in 2008 or nine,
you and I were sitting down the hill from your house,
that local coffee shop.
And we were talking about the Charlie monger book,
um,
that,
uh,
that big thick black
oh,
seeking wisdom seeking wisdom from monger to Darwin or maybe the other way
around by Peter beveling.
That's it.
Yes.
Yeah.
And,
um,
so that's a,
that's a fascinating book.
Well,
I'm glad to have turned you on to Oh yes.
I appreciate it.
So,
uh,
so after turning you onto that book,
I remember we were talking about like the books that changed our life and you
told me,
I think,
was it the magic of thinking big?
Yeah,
that's right.
Dave David Schwartz.
I have it face out on my shelf in my living room so that I can see it
constantly.
Okay.
So when you told me that the magic of thinking big made such a big difference to
you,
I think like the next week I picked it up and I read it and it did nothing for
me.
I still say,
you know,
and as to catch you at the right time.
Exactly.
And so that's why,
and it's also one of those books,
just,
sorry,
I'm getting defensive,
but it's one of those books that I read in around 2000 maybe a year or two after
college when I was in a Shitty,
you know,
a hundred plus hour a week job where I'm sleeping under my desk and sitting in
the fire exit because that's the only place they can,
they can fit me.
But yeah,
it has to find you at the right place at the right time.
Exactly.
And so there've been people that I tell about how Tony Robbins awaken the giant
within totally changed my life and I give it to friends and they go like,
Nah,
no,
no.
It did nothing for me.
So it,
you're right,
it does matter when you read a book.
Um,
even I noticed on a specific subject,
I read and loved stumbling on happiness loved that book.
And so I read like two or three more books on the subject of the study of
happiness.
And by the time it got to the third one,
I forget what it's called right now,
maybe happiness project or something like that,
whatever.
The third one I read was,
I remember flipping through the book quickly,
like,
yeah,
I know,
I know.
I got it.
And so I gave it a really bad rating on my website and somebody emailed me later
going,
hey,
that book changed my life.
I can't believe you get it.
Gave it a two out of 10 rating.
And I looked again at my notes and I thought,
you know,
it's actually probably a really good book.
I just read it at the wrong time because I had just read two other books on that
subject and so yeah,
exactly.
Just in a different order.
It might've been a 10 exactly.
If I would've read that one before,
stumbling on happiness,
which I gave a 10 to,
you know,
then I would have given that one a 10 and stumbling on happiness might've been
like,
yeah,
yeah.
I know this stuff already.
Stumbling on happiness is a,
is a,
is a great book.
I think that it's for those people who are familiar with the term that I use in
the four hour workweek,
the deferred life plan,
so a,
in other words,
sort of saving and working in order to retire at some point in the future,
maybe 10 20 years down the road,
30 perhaps to redeem all of that toil for some reward like sailing around the
world in a sailboat,
a stumbling,
I always forget,
is it something on or upon happiness?
Stumbling on half stumbling on happiness by Daniel Gilbert.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Uh,
is a great reality check for that type of,
I think extremely risky prone to failure.
Uh,
deferred life planning.
Yeah.
So I've got to tell you,
so we haven't really talked about this yet,
but this is so up your alley or your listeners Aliya for the people who were
into books will appreciate this.
So a lot of my friends,
actually,
I don't think any of my friends are as into reading as I am.
Okay.
A couple are,
but most aren't.
And so whenever I tell them about some amazing book I've read,
the,
the Gist I get from my friends,
it's like,
well just tell me what to do.
Right?
So like give me the index card.
Yeah.
Like they don't want to read the book.
And so my friend Jeff is a smart guy.
I mean he's,
he's a lawyer,
he's smart,
but he just looks at me with these tired eyes and he just says like,
I'm not gonna read the book dude.
Like,
just,
you can stop pushing it on me.
I just never going to happen.
He said,
just tell me what to do.
I trust you.
I like you.
You know me.
So tell me what to do.
And I realized that if you trust the source,
you don't need the arguments that,
so,
so much of a book is arguing it's point,
but often you don't need the argument.
If you trust the source,
you can just get the point.
So after reading,
taking detailed notes on 220 books on my site,
I realized that distilling wisdom into directives is so valuable,
but it's so rarely done.
In fact,
the only time I can think of that was done was a Michael Pollan with his three
books in a row about food,
each one getting shorter and shorter.
Um,
I think the,
the first one was,
uh,
was it like omnivores?
I'm a horse dilemma,
which was big.
So I know that you're the kind of guy that would,
it's a great book,
but also,
I mean,
they're like 70 pages on the,
on corn production in the US.
And most people just drop out.
Uh,
even I even,
I was like,
God,
my eyes are glazing over here,
but I know there's some good stuff coming so I'll,
I'll slug through it.
But yes,
very great book,
but a very big book.
And then he did one a year later that basically took the best of the stuff from
Omnivore's dilemma and made it into a shorter kind of more,
uh,
pop market.
Two to 300 page book,
I believe.
I forget the name of that one.
And had been in defense of food maybe it sounds right.
Yes.
Thank you.
Um,
so even that one,
I remember somebody telling me I should read it and me looking at it going like,
ah,
I don't know if I really want us to read 300 pages about food.
Um,
but then a year later he put out it any little book called food rules.
I think that's what it's called.
And it's like,
you basically can read the whole thing while just standing in the bookstore.
It's,
he took the energy and the effort to compress everything he's learned into very
succinct directives.
Uh,
and that's what is going,
you know,
sentences that tell you what to do,
do this,
do that or don't do that.
Uh,
if,
if your grandmother wouldn't recognize it as food,
don't eat it.
Uh,
and his tagline for that book,
the popular phrase was eat food,
mostly plants,
not too much.
Right.
And I so admired that I got inspired by the effort it takes to distill the blah,
blah,
blah down into the specific sentences for the people that just aren't going to
read that 900 page book,
right?
Like probably all of that same information is in the 900 page book,
but we just have to realistically admit that most people will never read the 900
page book.
So as I'm reading these 300 page books and 220 of them,
very often there'll be some like brilliant,
amazing,
important point on like page 290.
And I feel a little sad that almost nobody's going to read that.
Like I wished that these little tiny points were extracted like without all of
the surrounding argument.
So especially,
okay.
I'll admit,
this was also sparked by the idea of,
uh,
when I had a kid and I thought like,
I might not be alive when he's my age or even when he's 19,
I might die before he gets older.
How could I compress everything I've learned and that I think he should know
into a real succinct format that he will definitely read.
And then I of course,
then I thought,
and,
and you know,
other people will read too.
So I got under this idea of the do this project,
which is,
um,
instead of talking around the subject,
just giving directives saying,
do this,
do,
don't do this,
don't do that.
Which is kind of funny because it feels very presumptuous,
right?
Like who am I to tell others what to do?
But then I think,
well,
who am I not too right.
It's useful.
So get over myself kind of like you asked about like,
you know me on stage when I was 18.
What was the biggest lesson learned?
Like this isn't about me.
People aren't here about neither.
They're here for their own gain.
Even,
you know that,
oh,
you asked about my advice to Ted speakers.
That's my main advice to Ted speakers.
It's like people aren't here to see you and your life story.
People come to Ted or watch ted videos to learn something.
So just speak only about what is surprising and skip everything else.
Um,
what anyway,
if people could talk,
if we could start with one of your talks,
I know I'm interrupting for a second,
but which,
which,
which talk would you suggest as a starter?
My favorite one is the one,
I think on the Ted site it is called weird or just different,
I call it the Japanese addressing system.
That's my fault.
And I actually know what that means.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well it can be so confusing,
but yeah,
until somebody explains it to you and then you realize like,
oh,
it's just a different way of thinking.
And,
and here I'll just give you a little teaser.
The,
the,
the talk is only three minutes long.
So you go to ted.com and search for Derek Sivers and that's tall,
called weird or just different.
But the little teaser is,
is it blew my mind when I found out that in Japan they don't,
the reason the streets don't have names is because they think of the streets as
the empty unnamed spaces because the blocks are the things that have names,
the box or the piece of land with houses on them.
That's what's important.
Whereas in America and most of the world,
if,
if you say,
what is the name of that block?
People will look at you weird,
like bold.
This is oak street,
this is third avenue.
W what do you mean?
And they said,
well what does that block called?
And said that that doesn't have a name.
We don't name our blocks,
we name our streets.
The blocks are just the,
the unnamed spaces in between named streets.
So in Japan it's the opposite.
The streets are the empty unnamed spaces in between named a blogs.
So I realized that how many things in life actually work just as well,
the complete opposite way.
We're used to thinking of them both ways are correct.
So anyway,
that's the idea.
But the direct,
we were talking about directives.
Yes.
And the advice you give Ted speakers is just how I took us off track.
All right,
so go ahead.
No,
no,
no.
I was going to ask,
and I'm not trying to cut this short,
I'm just so I don't forget to ask,
where can people find the directives only in this podcast?
I know it's true.
I haven't done anything with it publicly.
I,
at first I thought I was going to make this into a big keynote speech I was
doing at a conference of the world domination summit conference in Portland.
I spent four months of full time work from like 7:00 AM to midnight for,
for you know,
seven days a week for four months in a row.
Just re reading all 220 book notes,
extracting a,
or trying to turn all of this advice or this knowledge,
this wisdom,
trying to turn it into directives because a lot of it almost never is in the
directive format already.
People talk around a subject,
they talk about findings and research,
but it takes some real effort to kind of like the,
um,
the old philosophers.
Um,
the,
was that you've read the,
the stoicism book,
uh,
the guide to the good life.
Yes.
I have that up on my living room wall as well.
So in that book he says,
right in the intro,
he said,
if you ask a modern person who calls himself a philosopher,
uh,
what should I do with my life?
He said,
get ready.
You know,
sit down and get comfortable because they will tell you.
Well,
it depends what you mean by what,
and it depends what you mean by do.
And really it depends what you mean by life or really maybe it depends on what
you mean by my life.
You know,
he said people are talking around the issue so much these days,
but he said back in 600 BC,
if you would've asked one of these philosophers,
what should I do with my life?
They would sit down and tell you exactly what to do with your life.
Do this,
don't do that,
pursue this.
Don't pursue that.
Uh,
so I was really inspired by that intro to,
so the idea was,
now how can I go back through all of these amazing books I've read and compress
all of this wisdom into specific directives.
So it took me four months of work to come up with the following like 18
sentences.
Do you want to hear them?
I do want to hear them.
I'm excited.
I'm super excited about this.
So this was going to be a 35 minute long keynote speech and it turned out to be
a horrible 35 minute long talk,
but it's entertaining for about three minutes.
So here's,
here's the three minute version.
Okay.
First I had fun categorizing them.
Uh,
so this is the category called how to be useful to others.
Ready?
I'm ready.
Number one,
get famous.
Do everything in public and for the public.
The more people you reach,
the more useful you are.
The opposite is hiding,
which is of no use to anyone,
how to be useful to others.
Number two,
get rich.
Money is neutral proof that you're adding value to people's lives.
So by getting rich,
you're being useful as a side effect.
Once rich spend the money in ways that are even more useful to others,
then getting rich is double useful.
How to be useful to others.
Share strong opinions.
Strong opinions are very useful to others.
Those who were undecided or ambivalent can just adopt your stance,
but those who disagree can solidify their stance by arguing against yours.
So even if you invent an opinion for the sole sake of argument,
boldly searing a strong opinion is very useful to others.
How to be useful to others.
Be Expensive.
People given a placebo pill were twice as likely to have their pain disappear
when told that that pill was expensive,
people who paid more for tickets were more likely to attend the performance.
So people who spend more for a product or service value it more and get more use
out of it.
So be expensive.
That's it.
Okay.
This is,
this is good stuff.
So that's how to be useful to others.
That's just one category.
I've got a few more if you want to hear them later.
Yeah.
Well,
let's,
what,
what is your favorite of the remaining categories?
Well,
maybe we could do one more.
Okay,
good.
If you imagine that I've got a few more that are done in that format.
Like I've got,
uh,
this is very stoicism.
Like I've got a whole category called how to thrive in an unknowable future
that's like prepare for the worst,
expect disaster,
own as little as possible.
Choose opportunity,
not loyalty.
She goes,
the plan.
Let's,
let's do that one is since,
I mean,
you know,
I'm a sucker for stoicism.
All right.
Uh,
let's,
let's talk about that one.
Okay.
So how to thrive in an unknowable future.
Prepare for the worst since you have no idea what the future may bring.
Be Open to the best and the worst,
but the best case scenario doesn't need your preparation or your attention.
Some mentally and financially.
Just prepare for the worst case instead.
And like insurance,
don't obsess on it.
Just prepare and then carry on.
Appreciating the good times.
How to thrive in an unknowable future.
Expect disaster.
If you ever watched a VH one behind the music,
you know that like every single success story had that moment where the narrator
would come in and say,
and then things took a turn for the worse.
Right?
So fully expect that disaster to come to you at any time.
You have to completely assume that it is going to happen and make your plans
accordingly.
Not just money,
but health and family and freedom.
You have to expect it to all disappear besides you appreciate things more when
you know this may be your last time seeing them.
Um,
how to thrive in an unknowable future,
own as little as possible depend on even less.
The less you own,
the less you're affected by disaster.
How to thrive in an unknowable future is choose opportunity,
not loyalty.
Have no loyalty to location corporation or your last public statements.
Be An absolute opportunist.
Doing whatever is best for the future in the current situation.
Unbound by the past,
have loyalty for only your most important human relationships.
How to thrive in an unknowable future.
Choose the plan with the most options.
The best plan is the one that lets you change your plans.
For example,
renting a house is actually buying the option to move at any time without losing
money in a changing market.
And lastly,
how to thrive in an unknowable future.
Avoid planning for maximum options.
Don't plan at all since you have no idea how the situation or your mood may
change in the future.
Wait until the last moment to make each decision.
Which,
which of these have you most concretely implemented in your life from this?
From this category?
Oh God.
Um,
I really internalize this category.
It's the whole way I see the world.
Like if you look inside my head,
you'd think I was a little nuts and just that I,
I'm just always expecting everything disappear even as I'm like,
I step outside and living in New Zealand now and I step outside,
it's just gorgeous surrounded by nature's blue skies and I,
I just inhale and I think like,
Yep,
this is all going to disappear.
It's all going to go to shit.
Polish is going to wreck this all.
But I don't think that in like a awful doom and gloom way,
you can tell.
I'm not,
you know,
er,
but it's just part of my appreciation for everything now and every person I know
and even just my health,
even just God when I like stand up in the morning and I'm like,
you know,
I just,
I wake up full of energy I think.
Yep.
In another couple of decades.
That's not going to happen anymore.
I really appreciate this.
So,
um,
yeah,
it's more of just a deep mindset.
It's a practical,
I give a short five minute talk on a called practical pessimism.
I think it was.
Yeah.
Stoicism as a productivity system.
I talked about this because I think it's so important that
not to be brainwashed into looking at everything with rose colored glasses
because it is not always a constructive exercise.
Uh,
in fact,
it can very much be the opposite.
And I,
the reason,
one of the primary reasons that I'm fasting right now,
I mean,
I'm eight days into a target of 10.
I'm getting a little little woozy today,
but all things mostly manageable is,
uh,
and I'm also,
this is what I haven't mentioned to you also unshaven also wearing the same,
mostly the same clothing pants,
jacket,
et Cetera,
all week long.
And the reason for that is actually a in,
in your,
what you just said reminded me a lot of Marcus Aurelius Meditations,
uh,
which were the emperor of Rome's wartime journal.
Never in tended for publication,
but it would always start with like,
today you are going to meet rude,
ungrateful,
arrogant people and the,
this is how you're going to contend with it.
And it was,
it seems very depressing until you realize that he was setting a,
creating a mindset that could deal with those worst case scenarios if they
presented themselves.
And similarly,
you know,
Seneca is very controversial,
stoic,
but nonetheless,
my,
my favorite to read,
uh,
and I have a huge,
like 30 hours of audio coming out related to Seneca shortly.
But one of his,
one of my favorite passages from Seneca is one that reads,
and I'm going to master this,
but it's paraphrased,
set aside some time each month where you,
yeah.
Subsist on the scanners to fair,
the cheap,
the roughest of dress,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Asking yourself all the while,
is this the condition I so feared?
And so not only are you mentally preparing yourself by visualizing the worst
case scenario,
you're actually practicing,
you're rehearsing poverty or lack of variation,
or in my case,
no food.
I've done this before with say rice and beans for five days,
and you're like,
okay,
it costs me $2 a day or less to eat and I feel fucking fine.
And in fact,
not having the paradox of choice,
having to go to the Thai restaurant and pick from 150 items that all have the
same six fucking ingredients that's been really relaxing and so on and so forth.
Uh,
so that's maybe a slight digression,
but,
um,
I've always appreciated that about how you have designed your life,
uh,
on the books.
So I want to,
I want to give,
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
I see it.
Before we close out this subject,
I have to just give you the one little like punchline ending to these directives
because there were some that didn't fit into this,
do this format,
do that.
And I didn't want to start making lists of what not to do because I liked the
idea that every single sentence should be actionable.
Right?
And so don't do this.
Don't do that.
Didn't feel actionable enough to me.
So I had fun kind of like,
you know,
our mutual hero,
Charlie monger had a speech once that I think he gave at USC about like how to
be a failure.
And it was so I made a category that was called how to stop being rich and
happy.
So this is like after you're rich and happy,
how to stop being rich and happy.
And I thought you'd appreciate this first one.
Prioritize lifestyle design.
You've made it so it's all about you now.
Make your dreams come true.
Shape your surroundings to please your every desire.
Make your immediate gratification.
The most important thing,
uh,
how to stop being rich and happy.
Chase that comparison moment.
You have the old thing,
you want the new thing.
Yes.
Do it be happy for a week.
Ignore the fact that happiness comes only from the moment of comparison between
the old and new.
Once you've had your new thing for a week and it becomes your new normal,
then just go seek happiness from another new thing.
Yeah.
You get the idea.
No,
I do.
And I agree with the first point.
I mean,
people might think that I wouldn't,
but they're doing a lot of reading and uh,
your practice with meditation and so on.
But if you read,
say Tara Brock or,
uh,
which has,
she is a fantastic book called radical acceptance,
which I highly recommend to people who are type A in particular,
but,
uh,
most suffering,
Angie,
Tony Robbins would say this to my,
I attended my first live event
a few weeks ago,
which was very fascinating and lot of fun.
But,
uh,
the most suffering comes from a focus on me on the self.
And as soon as you get,
I received a piece of advice a few,
maybe five years ago from someone they said,
if you're having trouble making yourself happy,
just make someone else happy.
And it sounds so cliched,
but it's actually really pragmatic and it makes me think of this something
simple that I've been doing that,
uh,
Gabrielle Reece,
Gabby Reese,
who was on this podcast with Laird Hamilton,
uh,
both very famous athletes and they're married and she said,
go first.
And all she meant by that was during your day.
Be First.
Like if be the first to look at someone and smile and be the first to look,
to walk up to when you walk up to the Barista,
ask them how they're doing,
be the first to initiate that.
And it's such a simple way to put a smile on people's faces.
Not always,
but a good portion of the time.
And that can change your own state.
Uh,
two things on,
on books.
I'll just,
because you're sharing your methods,
I'll share a couple that I've enjoyed.
One is on Amazon.
I will look at the four star most for if it has a sufficient critical mass of
say five stars to be worth looking into.
If that's how I'm I'm filtering,
then I will look at the most helpful critical reviews that are,
that are four and three star.
Uh,
in addition to that,
I will go to,
I think it's just kindle.amazon.com and I will read the public highlights.
So I'll take,
uh,
maybe five minutes to look at the most critical three and four star reviews
because the,
the five star and the one star and two star tend to be worthless in a way.
Yes.
They're so one sided.
Yeah.
Uh,
so look at the,
the three and four star most helpful critical reviews.
And then I will look at the kindle highlights and that is in effect seeing the
movie trailer.
It's like if you don't like the highlights from the movie trailer,
you're definitely not going to like the full feature film,
especially when it takes 30 hours instead of one and a half.
And,
uh,
the reason I started using a kindle was specifically so that I could export my
notes yes.
As text files.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
the,
so that's,
that's one of the ways that I filter books these days.
Um,
but the,
the,
uh,
the question that I always ask that I'd like to ask you and,
I think we might have to do around two sometime because we'll can probably going
to have to hop off and,
uh,
maybe 10 minutes or so,
but what,
there's so many questions I want to ask you.
Uh,
what is the book you've given most as a gift Geek in Japan,
in Japan,
Geek in Japan by Hector Garcia?
Because I'm,
I'm fascinated with the mindset
of a place,
right?
Like,
I would love to really understand the philosophy of Brazil,
India,
China,
Finland,
France,
Japan,
Thailand.
Like to me,
each place it seems to have its own cultural norms in how it approaches time or
longterm versus short term thinking or what's precious sent should be protected
or human interactions,
relationships,
dealing with obstacles,
conformity versus rebellion.
Uh,
or just,
you know,
how it approaches,
uh,
people who are unfortunate.
So we think of philosophies like existentialism,
Stoicism,
Nihilism.
But I'd love to study Brazil,
Ism,
Japan,
tie ism,
you know,
I really do think of each country's culture is kind of like a,
uh,
working modern applied philosophy.
Oh,
totally,
totally.
Yeah.
So Geek in Japan is written by the Spanish guy who's been living in Japan for 10
years.
And while most of the book is kind of like,
hey,
check out this,
look at that.
It has a section in the middle that I think explains the Japanese mindset better
than anything I'd heard before.
And I had spent months in Japan over the last 20 years.
I've gone there five or six times and I used to play guitar for a Japanese pop
star and toured the country.
But Somehow Geek in Japan made me understand Japan more.
So I give that to everyone who's going to Japan.
But actually an even better book I've found since then and describing the
mindset of a country is called AU contraire.
Figuring out the French,
it's so deep.
It explains the mindset so well,
I wish there was a book like this about every country I highly recommended.
So you listeners out there,
if you know of any other books like this that like explain the mindset of a
country,
please email me to let me know
there is a book and I'm going to rely on the readers as well.
What is your email address if you want to give it out?
Yeah,
Derek sivers.org and uh,
in the comments guys.
So this,
all the show notes and everything links to these books will
be@fourhourworkweek.com forward slash Derek.
Uh,
but there is a book out there,
I want to say Enrico something as the author,
but an Italian,
I'm pretty sure it was an Italian,
effectively writes geek in America,
but from the standpoint of Italian traveling through the u s including the
heartland.
Nice.
Uh,
so that's,
that's one.
Cool.
Uh,
what's $100 or less purchase has most positively impacted your life in the last
six months or recently?
Well,
I'm such a minimalist that I always avoid letting any new possession into my
life.
Right.
But I took my three year old kid to a cafe one morning that had a huge box of
toys,
like little figurines and color cars and dolls and monsters.
And he was just in the zone for like two or three hours,
completely engrossed in all these toys.
So I was like,
yeah,
okay.
Can't,
you know,
push my minimalist and on on him.
He needs toys.
So that night I went on to Ebay and I found someone selling a huge box of old
use toys just like that,
you know,
figurines and cars and stuff.
20 bucks and a endless hours of entertainment since best $20 I've spent on a
lawn.
That's awesome.
Uh,
do you have a favorite documentary or movie?
No.
Um,
I really don't watch hardly anything.
I don't,
I mean relative to the norm,
right?
I mean,
I watch movies,
but more kind of for the artistry,
the cinematography and I listened to music of course,
but like,
I don't watch ted talks or documentaries or TV shows.
I also,
I don't even read blogs or articles and I don't listen to podcasts.
In fact,
I listened to my very first podcast two weeks ago.
That was the one with you and Tony Robbins.
That was like the first time I've ever listened to a podcast because I just have
this lovely optimized life.
Or I just wake up and I write,
write,
all day long.
I have no commute.
I,
I'm never really driving anywhere.
So I don't have any downtime like that.
And if I'm outside,
I want to hear the birds and the trees,
you know?
And if I'm working out,
I'll either crank up the hip hop or sometimes just enjoy the total silence
except for the hardcore sound of the clanking metal plates,
you know?
So I really just prefer books as my medium of learning an input of information
and take.
What do you listen to?
What are you listening to now or recently for working out what music?
Huh?
I've started realizing that,
I don't know my American history of hip hop,
that I've always been loosely aware of it,
but I recently saw the
Chris rock movie top five and the running punch line in that movie.
He's like,
he's going around like what are your top five and people kind of name their top
five hip hop artists are the ones that they feel are like the most important and
there were some in there I'll realize like,
well I don't,
I've actually,
I know who these people are.
Of course we've all heard of Krs one and rock him and,
but I was like,
wait,
I don't think I actually know their music well.
So I've started giving myself an education in the history of hip hop and so
lately I've been listening to nothing but hip hop.
Going back to the very beginning,
the wild style movie and the kind of early stuff and giving myself the
chronological history of hip hop.
It's been fun.
Any favorites so far?
I would say if you'd Eric B and Rakim our way up at the top for me,
especially once I understood the context.
When you hear the before and after,
like right now you can take rock him for example.
Uh,
I mean you can take them for granted the way that now if you listen to Jimi
Hendrix,
you can take what he was doing for granted because people have expanded on that.
But if you think of like where what people were doing with guitars before Jimi
Hendrix and after it was just mind blowing.
And so I think Rakim is like that for hip hop,
that it's,
he listened to what was going on before him and then he came along.
It was just such a,
um,
such a whole new approach to change everybody's since if you have one billboard
anywhere with anything on it,
what would it say?
Well,
my real answer if I was taking that literally is that I would remove all the
billboards in the world and ensure that they were never replaced,
you know,
like,
have you ever driven through India?
You know?
Yeah.
It's so sad.
I haven't driven,
it was on my way to the Calcutta er where I spent a week.
I was gone briefly looking at the windows,
you know,
even in these small towns and Carola,
like there's almost no space that is left without advertising.
So I really admire those places.
Like I think Vermont and a South Paulo,
Brazil,
that ban,
uh,
billboards.
But I know that that wasn't really what you were asking.
So,
so my better answer is,
um,
I think I would make a billboard that would say it won't make you happy and I
would place it outside any big shopping mall or a car dealer.
So ideally,
actually I think,
you know,
it'd be a fun project is to buy and train thousands of parrots to say it won't
make you happy.
It won't make you happy.
And then you let them loose in the shopping malls and super stores around the
world.
That's my life mission.
Anybody again,
anybody with me?
Let's do it.
Yeah.
We'll make you happy.
Uh,
very stoic,
very stoic.
Uh,
which does not mean you can't have joy in your life,
but it's think stumbling on happiness is,
is a great one for people to Peruse.
Do you have notes on stumbling on happiness on that's on there.
All right,
great.
So we will link to that.
Okay.
Last effectively last question.
I'll give you one or two more and then I think we might have to sometime soon
and talk about around too if people are interested.
So if you'd like to hear more with Derrick,
please let me know.
At t Ferris on the Twitter,
t,
f e R R,
I s s Niga lupins at sippers as well.
What advice would you give your 30 year old self and,
and place us if you would for where you were at 30 and what you were doing?
Hmm.
At 30?
Well,
let's see.
I had just,
I just started CD baby at 30,
but I think,
uh,
I think the biggest advice I would give to my younger self or more like
knowledge learned,
like,
Hey,
younger self,
you should know this now is that women like sex know that until I was 40.
I think I didn't get that.
I think through,
you know,
like teenage movies or whatever,
we're kind of taught the opposite.
That's like,
you know,
men always want sex and women don't,
I don't know why the media portrays it like that,
but later I found out that's not true.
But I think the,
the more interesting answer is that my advice to my 30 year old self would be,
um,
don't be a donkey.
And so does that mean,
well,
I meet a lot of 30 year olds that are trying to pursue many different directions
at once but not making progress in any right.
And then,
or,
or they get frustrated that the world wants them to pick one thing because they
want to do them all.
And I get a lot of this frustration like,
but I want to do this and that and this and that.
Why do I have to choose?
I don't know what to choose.
But the problem is if you're thinking short term,
then you're acting as if you don't do them all this week that they won't happen.
But I think the solution is to think longterm to realize that you can do one of
these things for a few years and then do another one for a few years.
And then another.
So what I mean about don't be a donkey is you've probably heard the fable about
think its burdens donkey,
who it's a fable about a donkey that is standing halfway in between a pile of
hay and a bucket of water and he just keeps looking left to the hay or right to
the water trying to decide,
hey,
or water,
hay or water.
He's unable to decide.
So he eventually falls over and dies of both hunger and thirst.
So the point is that a donkey can't think of the future.
If he did,
he'd clearly realized that he could just go first to drink the water and then go
eat the hay.
So my advice to my 30 year old self is don't be a donkey.
That you can do everything you want to do.
You just need foresight and patients,
right?
So say like for somebody listening,
if you're 30 years old now and say you have like five different things you want
to pursue,
right?
Well then you can do each one of those for 10 years and you'll have them all
done by the time you're 80,
you're probably going to live to be 80.
So it's,
it's ridiculous too.
I mean it sounds ridiculous to plan to the age of 80 when you're 30.
Right.
But it's a fact that is probably coming,
so you might as well take advantage of it.
It's like use the future then that way you can fully focus on one direction at a
time without feeling,
you know,
conflicted or distracted because you know that you'll get to the others in the
future.
And I think you could also just to build on that,
I agree.
I think most people,
and this is not something I've thought up on my own,
but underestimate,
they overestimate what they can achieve in a day or a week.
So they've 20 items on their to do list,
but they underestimate what they could achieve in a year or even two years.
And yet you're the way that you're,
for instance,
if you look at a lot of what I've done,
much of which ended up being,
uh,
a result of accidental discoveries,
but you're the,
the book career.
But then you had the angel investing started around 2007,
2008 and I treated that as a two year self self imposed MBA and it was like,
okay,
I want to try this and really focus on it for two years and I'm not going to
expect to have any financial return,
but just as an Mba I'm going to sink this amount of cost into it.
Uh,
which was identical,
the Stanford Graduate School of business at the time and assume that the network
and relationships and lessons I would learn to be worth that two years.
And just viewing them as to your experiments.
Uh,
which I did with the TV also,
which did not turn out as ideally as I would've liked.
Although I though very proud of,
you know,
the Tim Ferriss experiment podcast.
Same thing,
right?
It wasn't a three year commitment,
but it was also not a one day or one week commitment.
It was like,
okay,
I'm going to do this for at least six episodes.
Maybe it takes me six months and then I'll correct course at that point.
But uh,
yeah,
you do.
I think a lot of 30 year olds feel pressured or younger or older for that matter
to pursue many,
many things in parallel when if you were just a tweak that slightly and make
them cereal,
the results would be much better.
Yeah,
that's a really hard lesson to learn.
We can even say it right now,
but uh,
it's,
it's really tough.
I even find that now.
Yeah.
It's a constant challenge.
Uh,
the five minute journal I find very helpful.
I've mentioned this before to people,
but so I won't Belabor the point,
but um,
people can check that out if they want it to go or the pomodoro technique also
really helpful.
Uh,
okay.
We are going to wrap this first conversation up for,
for our dear public,
but do you have any asks or requests of my audience before we close up?
Not really.
I mean,
honestly,
the main reason I do interviews like this,
like public ones instead of you and I just,
you know,
sitting on the phone and shooting the shit is that,
is that I really like the people that I meet through them,
like the kind of people that would listen to hours into this conversation or my
kind of people.
So I usually just tell people,
just email me.
Um,
Derek sivers.org.
I read them,
I kind of enjoy putting aside a little time each day to,
to read emails and I answer every single one.
Um,
because I said hell yeah or no to the rest of my life,
so I've got time to do it.
So yeah,
that's it.
Just feel free to email me if you have any questions or anything.
We're just to say hi.
Awesome.
And uh,
for those people who do not want to wait for round two,
uh,
Derek,
you're hilarious.
I put out a tweet recently,
which was,
what should I ask?
What would you like me to ask at Sivers?
Uh,
I'm going to be interviewing him soon and
I couldn't ask any of them because you went online and basically answered all of
them on Twitter.
So if you search at t Ferris,
two r's to us as an at silver as you will see,
or you could just look at,
um,
at my tweet and the various responses and then Derek's responses,
it's still almost all of them.
Uh,
you can get a,
um,
an encore performance and uh,
and it just had the chance I had the feeling we probably weren't going to get to
all of those questions so you know better to answer them with a tiny punch line.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
No,
no.
Fantastic.
Well,
Derek,
as always,
so much fun to jam,
we need to spend more time in person soon and thanks so much for taking the
time.
Of course.
Thanks.
All right.
And everybody listening,
thank you all for listening.
We're done.
Redundancy of department redundancy and uh,
he,
the show notes as always.
Uh,
you can find for all episodes of four hour work week.com forward slash podcast
for this episode,
specifically@afourhourworkweek.com forward slash.
Derek.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend and five bullet Fridays,
a very short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends,
for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour workweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
[inaudible] this episode
is brought to you by me undies.
If I'm not going commando,
I'm in the Andes.
I have been testing these underwear for three to four months now,
pretty much every day and in fact,
throughout bunch of my other underwear this morning and on the road in the
house,
they are extremely comfortable.
They look good,
feel good.
They are made of micro modal,
two times softer than cotton and scientifically tested using the call.
Bottom method sounds very fancy of course,
and I get a lot of compliments from ladies for these.
You don't get diaper butt,
you don't get the tired elastic band.
They look great and they have underwear for both men and women.
Check out [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim and you can see everything that
I've been wearing.
They're ridiculous.
The sublime,
everything in between,
including my favorite,
which is called out.
And I would be remiss if I didn't mention their lounge pants.
This is a new thing and I've been wearing their lounge pants when I record
podcast.
I've been wearing them out and about when I'm walking the dog meeting people for
coffee and they are extremely comfortable.
They're made from the same material as the underwear,
but some of them,
like the blue ones,
I have have pockets so you can walk about without seeming like you're off of
your meds and completely crazy.
So that is awesome.
And if you're not happy with the first pair you try on,
I assume that first of the underwear,
they'll refund you completely and you can keep the pair you tried on for free.
But if you're that kind of person,
you should be ashamed because that's disgusting.
Uh,
[inaudible] dot com slash Tim check it out.
This episode is brought to you by Wealthfront and this is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive in a good way.
Set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under management.
In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why?
Why is it so popular?
Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously reserved for the ultra wealthy,
but only pay pennies on the dollar for them,
and this is because they use smarter software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams,
et cetera.
And I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz,
which only takes two to five minutes and they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they'd put you in.
And if you just want to take their advice,
run with it,
do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it.
Here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular basis but normally aren't.
Great investing is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may or may not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of time.
Wealthfront,
as I mentioned,
since it's using software instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low costs that were previously completely
impossible right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim that is less than $5 a month to invest a
$30,000 account for instance.
Now,
normally when I have a sponsor on this show,
it's because I use them and recommend them.
In this case,
it's a little different.
I don't use Wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed to.
Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of SCC regulations,
companies that invest your money are not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user end have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money,
at least for me,
uh,
in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if you decide to open an account.
But just start with seeing the portfolio that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes,
fill out their questionnaire@wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim,
it's fast,
it's free.
There's no downside that I can think of.
So check it out guys.
This is one of the hottest,
most innovative companies coming out of Silicon Valley and they're killing it.
They've become massively popular.
Just take a look,
see what portfolio they would create for you,
and you can use that information however you want.
wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim and until next time,
thank you for listening.